after seven of nine rounds here at the
st. Louis Invitational everyone's
priority is different if you ask some
players they're looking to win their
entire field others are still looking to
norm it is still possible at this stage
in the big tournament samsa be on in the
running to get his Jam norm and Andre
gaurav its has to win both to get his
cadent rope looking to finish over 2500
today Sam Semyon defeated John
barthelemy with white to bring his score
25 points he's had a pretty good
tournament he's won his last two games
and if he wins a point and a half more
he will have his second Grand Master
norm well f five out of seven and I have
to get one and a half out of 24 norm I
have a severe cold I was really a lot of
allergies at this time of year um I
think we both prepared the same line
saru Lopez and then we get into Spanish
zaya I prepared this line d5 basically
the point is now that after he plays he
sick because his Bishop is kind of
looking at this brick wall he has to
play c6 and after I take on c6 first
this night goes away I take on six he
has a good d 5 squared and well he has
two defenders of the thief oxfords
tonight so I want to get rid of [ __ ]
first this one he can't move it because
it's a pin and he played h6 because he
wants to get rid of this Bishop first
but after this I plan a g4 and I get rid
of the second defender so if you leave
then basically he leaves the d5 square
and I can play Bishop b3 and control the
square and then this night comes to d5
so he took on g4 and now he said he was
surprised after i took with a pawn
because theory says this is the move
because now black can't play this move d
5 as after take take 93 my bishop is
open on the lime diagonal and my nights
coming to f5 the differences if i take h
takes d4 d5 he takes the Queen takes D
and he's threatening me so I can't avoid
the Queen exchange after Bishop d7 well
he wants to put pressure on the c3 pawn
and the g4 pond but I have an easy way
to defend from that Bishop b3 rook c8
fix you one now my night wants to go to
d5 so he won't exchange it for this bad
bishop on fa
he's attacking America so I played
bouquet one because I want to open the a
file with a for it takes me five then
put their work on the seventh fret with
Luke a seven so he has no real stop to
this product because this move I play a
four and i still have to open file on
this path before so he tried to win this
g4 pump but he has no time because he
has a weak v5 phone ok so now I double
room whenever he takes this pawn I
player k 7 and he loses f7 for example
here 97 or if he goes back I take this
pawn so he played the rook c8 Rick 86 I
didn't want to exchange rooks because he
has to pass the works and I have two
active please I played rukka 6 I want to
play I want a fork him at night be sick
so he got rid of this Bishop because if
he continues to passively I think like
this now he can't play B should be 16 I
over 100 k 7
yeah now i want to invite into the
eighth-ranked and I think he's already
I'm starting to start a very strong
attack I mean if you take Sunday eight
for example I take actually this was the
game if we played we played King age
seven because if you played rook c7 I
would exchange then I'll take this pawn
in this and Queenie a check is coming
and made on G so you play teenage seven
but now my tech is just too strong and
well he has his own friends but with
this move I just stop everything Myrick
wants to complete you probably his last
chance was to play g6 but we were both
playing on the increment here so it's
hard friends point after this iphone
stupid move Queen B 1 now I check him
and I want a bishop d1 Bishop takes H
path and will his kick is open so pretty
much the game was over bday master Seth
Houma is only a one and a half points
away from achieving an international
master norm he has two rounds to do it
there's one day left of play sunday june
first 2014 catch it live online as it
happens move by move at twelve noon
central at st. Louis chess club that'll
work